first tonight the mass are finally
coming off finally even in far left
states like new york and illinois but
while the mandates are finally coming to
an end there's one weird bizarre
puzzling exception in many blue states
children you know the ones that have a
zero percent statistical cover 19 death
rate that aren't impacted like older
people and people with comorbidities
people obese people with pre-existing
conditions compromised immune systems
yeah the least likely people to get
seriously ill from coven they're still
forcing your children to wear masks in
school and other public settings this
isn't about science this is about health
it's not about health or safety either
or the spread of covet democrats
teachers unions they are playing
politics with the well-being of your
children and the last thing these people
want to do is what they keep telling us
to do follow the science according to
multiple studies face masks are harming
the development of our kids a report in
usa today details how first graders are
way behind in reading kids are also
having a harder time making friends and
recognizing faces
speaking and motor skills apparently
also are impaired one three-year-old in
new jersey was kicked out of speech
therapy
but not wearing their mask others are
forced out of school altogether you have
29 students in loudoun county in
virginia suspended for mass violations
despite governor younkin's order making
masks optional he'll join us in a minute
meanwhile in the bronx in new york and
in new york city two high schoolers were
suspended they weren't wearing their
masks but here is the idiotic fill in
new york uh governor kathy hulkel making
zero sense in the bronx no mass
surrounded by
mass children and this week she ended
the mass mandate for adults but not for
the people least that are the least
vulnerable you know and not for the
people that are at least
impacted by this the kids now here is
wannabe governor of georgia or in her
mind still governor of georgia stacy
abrams and she fully supports all the
mass mandates for kids but she can't be
bothered to be a good example and wear
one herself because of her age alone
never mind maybe any comorbidity she may
have abrams is at a much higher risk for
kova 19 than any one of those kids with
their mask on in that room and yet she's
the only one not wearing the mask now
here is a 70 year old lady jill biden
also no mass surrounded by kids all
wearing masks and here is 64 year old
teachers union boss randy weingarten
massless on msdnc demanding your kids
continue to wear masks take a look
what dr mcbride just told us about mass
not particularly being effective for
children what's the argument against
taking off masks in schools well the
argument is that you have well let me
just say this
i am in favor of an off ramp on mass
right the real issue becomes
are is the is
is the spread
low enough
so that there's no dissemination or
transmission in schools now don't forget
randy weingarten was a advocate of
virtual learning and has been for a
while for months she tried to keep
schools closed and randy weigarten
doesn't give a rip about the well-being
of your kids and meanwhile the always
honest always trustworthy always
consistent you know i knew all about the
funding of the wuhan virology lab but
i'm lying about it dr anthony fauci and
dr rachelle walinski also want to make
sure that your kids stay masked at all
times forget the science take a look we
understand what what
governors are saying we also want to
make sure that people are safe and the
cdc has not amended our guidance right
now we continue to recommend masking in
schools for everyone we continue to
recommend masking in public indoor
settings in areas of higher substantial
transmission and that right now is
everywhere in the country um what are
your thoughts on children first of all
needing to wear masks at school and what
do you think about the possibility we're
going to be able to lift
well certainly there will come a time
hopefully
a bit later when we will be able to lift
the mask mandate
in general including to school but we're
not there yet
i am so sick of hearing his voice seeing
him on tv he's been wrong the entire
time and again children are the least
likely to get seriously ill or die from
culver 19. that doesn't matter to the
so-called experts because the experts
don't really care about real science
only convenience science or risk
analysis or common sense none of that
applies they only care about optics my
prediction in a few days maybe a few
weeks they will suddenly recommend masks
are no longer needed they will say the
science is magically changed when in
reality it's going to be public opinion
that changes in an election year and
their power is the only thing that will
change their mind and clinging on to
that power now we are already seeing
this at fake news cnn they have a top
so-called medical expert her name is dr
lyanna nguyen and she is the former
president of planned parenthood former
health commissioner for the city of
baltimore so obviously she's extremely
trustworthy and competent dr wen
recently said that she now favors
lifting mask mandates because science
has changed five months ago she was
arguing that unvaccinated americans
should not be allowed to leave their
homes
in america now of course in just five
months the science hasn't changed but
the polls have and a new republican
governor was elected in the commonwealth
of virginia after promising to end
draconian culvert 19 mandates and
empowering parents and letting them
decide after he was sworn in as governor
governor younkin began implementing his
campaign promises and for the simple act
of fulfilling his popular proposals that
got him elected in a purple to blue
state that is virginia many on the left
are vilifying yunkan now the washington
post you can check it almost every day
they smear him now nearly on a daily
basis for no logical reason except they
hate anybody that's conservative jim
acosta quivered as he announced that
glenn younkin was turning virginia into
a soviet-style police state
by making masks
optional
liberal school boards in northern
virginia defy duncan's executive order
on masks spending massless sending
massless students apparently home and
you know trying to stick it to the new
republican governor now these democrats
are playing political football but the
people they're playing football with are
your kids
thankfully they're losing the virginia
senate by the way controlled by
democrats they just voted to end the
mass mandates in schools by a whopping
margin of 29 to nine as younkin stated
quote this vote shows that school boards
are attacking their own students they're
suddenly detached from stunningly
detached from reality and it's time to
put kids first and get back to normal
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else